all right all right we are back we are
back we have raul paul that we're gonna
bring up here uh he is the founder of
real vision he is one of the most
thoughtful people when it comes to the
macro economy and he has gone deep down
the bitcoin and crypto rabbit hole uh
roll can you hear me
of course i can yeah how are you i'm i'm
doing great uh let's start with macro
structure first uh it feels like there
was massive chaos last year uh for
anyone who was paying attention to the
podcast you and i recorded in person in
march of 2020 uh and you pretty much
nailed it you
that was quite a famous podcast i think
yes and a lot of people were like oh
raul's just being a doomsdayer you know
he's just calling uh the market's gonna
turn over this is gonna be bad and then
like within a week and a half everyone
thought the market was going to zero
right i mean it just got real bad real
fast we obviously had the government
step in we had the interest rate
manipulation we had all the monetary and
fiscal stimulus uh and now we get all
the way up until today how do you
evaluate where we are from a macro
standpoint at the current moment
so i think it's interesting i always
follow narratives and the narrative
right now is
very much on this inflation ongoing
growth
how the fed going to raise rates to have
to taper soon
but the work that i've been doing
suggests that
the likelihood is the economy the global
economy slows down
pretty significantly uh into next year
and again we might see more stimulus
and more fiscal stimulus coming as well
so
i look at it very differently to what
most people are seeing but on the
horizon because of like the fiscal cliff
we've got like three and a half percent
of gdp coming off from the fiscal cliff
we've got all of the spending brought
forward that everybody including me did
up their houses over the over the
previous year
um we've also got the fact that oil
prices have gone up that hits household
expenditure um prices in general hit
household expenditure you see these
weird old things like the michigan
university of michigan surveys about
cars houses and durable goods because
the prices all went up basically they've
gone to all-time lows in terms of
affordability so people are stepping
back we're seeing in the housing market
we're seeing all over the place so these
higher prices are kind of a cure for
higher prices
as is often the case and i think that
that's going to lead to much slower
growth than we expect and again as i
said more stimulus and so when we get
slower growth and more stimulus does
that continue to drive the prices higher
and higher and it's almost like a
negative feedback loop because as the
prices go higher growth slows and we
become more and more dependent on that
kind of that external
stimulus
i'm not sure that prices go higher um
that's a supply-driven issue that i
think eventually disappears
um assets go higher and you know that in
itself has been a problem something you
and i have discussed because if you
can't buy a house because you're 32
years old and your income doesn't go up
because nobody's income is really going
up um then you're kind of getting
screwed you know that's one of the whole
premises behind you know why i got very
very interested in in bitcoin early on
we're seeing this play through and i
think it's just going to continue i
think
there's so much debt in the system
there's so much leverage i think the
world is now 400 and 400 of gdp in debt
that governments have now realized in
the central banks that they can't let
the collateral go bust i the asset side
of the balance sheet is not allowed to
fall in price
um because if not you get a big margin
call on the economy
so it seems to be that debasement of
currency to drive assets higher
optically
is the only answer they've got now
there's almost no way around it unless
they can generate growth that is
reasonably is higher than previous trend
for a longer period of time and with
this aging population all of this
indebtedness globalization technology
the chances of doing that are low
so one of the things that we spend a lot
of time talking about is if you look at
like a chipotle let's use them as a
proxy for
kind of hourly wages they raised wages
three to four percent they then passed
that through to menu prices up three to
four percent but if you look at somebody
like i think it was blackrock they
increased the uh
firm wide salaries eight percent it's
almost double and so you almost get this
like bifurcation you get kind of
white-collar workers where they really
understand inflation et cetera much
higher increase but at least they both
increased right so there is some uh
negating of the levels of inflation um
when you start to think about the
everyday person whether they are a
white-collar worker uh or they work an
hourly job or maybe they're coming off
of unemployment and just now kind of
coming back into the workforce what is
likely to be
kind of their experience if we continue
to see asset prices go up uh wages don't
necessarily go up nearly as much and the
government steps in is this in the form
of uh just more kind of unemployment
boost and direct stimulus checks and we
eventually move towards like a ubi world
or is there something else that you
think this could take the form of i
don't know and i don't think anybody's
figured it out but the problem is as you
as you're saying it's right wages don't
go up enough the other thing that's
missing from that wage construct is the
fact that all the boomers are retiring
in record numbers so that's offsetting
the amount of total demand in the
economy because a bunch of people go on
no salary apart from on their savings
they didn't really save that much and
then a few others get wage rises but if
you look at the debasement of the fiat
currencies overall that's going
somewhere around 13 15 a year so that's
driving up asset prices at
a minimum of 15 percent a year so even
if your wages go up four you're the
chipotle worker well suddenly you still
can't afford as much of the s p and you
still can't afford um as much you know a
house and all of the same things so
you're still getting net poorer so what
is an asset that's the important thing
for people to understand here an asset
is basically deferred expenditure so you
stick savings into something that you
hope goes up enough in price to offset
inflation and other things and then
eventually you get to spend it by
selling that asset now whether that's
gold or whether it's a house
particularly if it's a second home that
you're trying to rent out or do that
kind of stuff
so
those assets which are your future
wealth
are becoming harder to buy so you can
buy less often
so you are net getting poorer and i
don't know how you're going to solve
that equation i think the next bet is
that fiscal stimulus will do it
but i don't think that's going to be the
case because the chipotle worker is
going to be laid off by robots and as
simple as that we're seeing in
mcdonald's we're seeing in many places
so between artificial intelligence and
robotics you're going to be competing
um for salary
with with somebody who gets
exponentially cheaper in price because
computing power gets exponentially
cheaper
so it's a it's a really really difficult
situation so i think they're going to
continue with the same path for the time
being
by the time the next recession comes
then i think that's a full roller roll
out of ubi because there's no way around
it
um i don't see how you rescue this
situation by doing the same thing again
and again we know the outcome we've seen
it since 2008
and nothing's going gonna change with
that
last time we talked uh in 2020 um at
least you had mentioned this idea of
bonds and you know now with inflation on
the cpi basis being up over five percent
uh pretty much every bond that is held
by pension plans uh endowments
foundations etc is negative yielding on
a real return basis how does that play
out uh kind of across the financial
markets and then obviously for uh some
of these organizations that whether it's
for salary or for retirement purposes
people are really counting on
so it depends whether you think
inflation in that cpi measure not this
debasement measure the cpi measure stays
over five percent i don't i don't i
think it's absolutely structurally
impossible because of demographics debt
um
globalization and technology so i don't
think that's possible
but we've also seen that in europe and
japan
the institutional sector has been
happily buying negative yielding bonds
for i don't know best part of a decade
now
so those that bonds continue but that
again is just locking in some sort of
relative level of poverty so so you know
you owning bonds and your pension plan
owning bonds is really making you worse
off over time i mean bonds can be a
trade and that's fine and i think you
know
bonds probably rally for the next nine
months but
overall you're still not going to make
enough money out of that to paper over
the cracks in how much money is being
kind of stolen from you
by inflation at the time being and then
debasement which i think is the biggest
structural problem
let's talk about uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies and crypto assets uh
let's start first with just what is your
portfolio look like right now i know uh
you were kind of all bitcoin then you
went bitcoin and ether uh what does that
look like today so we just understand
the perspective you're coming from
um my current allocation
is probably 70 percent
eth five percent bitcoin
and then a tale of
others
so why that allocation it's nothing
against bitcoin it's not against
anything else it's because i'm a
financial markets guy and we use risk
curves so at certain points in the cycle
in the middle of a bull market you want
to take as much risk as possible so you
want to go to the
more speculative end of the market
so
firstly you know i isolated the fact
that i thought ethereum was going to see
further flows it's early in this
adoption cycle and that will probably
drive prices further than bitcoin and
that seems to be playing out with the
others there's so much going on it's
difficult to monitor so i i have kind of
basically a relatively broad-based
portfolio to capture some of that move
when the tail goes up i either furthest
risk out and that happens in credit
markets equity markets all over the
place in equity markets in a in a bull
market you tend to get the big leaders
first which is where the safe money is
the blue chips then eventually people
move to emerging markets and then they
move to frontier markets and it's in
order to get more bang for your buck in
the middle of the cycle and generate
some alpha so it's not a
it's not a comment per se on my relative
view on the success of protocols or
something like bitcoin it's nothing to
do with that it's about how do i
make money
out of this crypto investment whilst
maintaining my my um level of interest
in the overall crypto world and so
that's where i am now where would it be
in a year's time maybe it's much more
bitcoin again so it's just that it's an
asset allocation strategy to try and
enhance rewards so this is really
fascinating because i think that uh
using the legacy market as uh a mirror
if you will to the crypto market is i
think uh what people can kind of wrap
their head around and you're talking
about these cycles of kind of bull and
bear markets and so if you were uh
allocated to bitcoin in 2017 being in
2017 it went up 20 x 1 000 to 20 000
other assets went up more than 20 x uh
but then in the bear market bitcoin drew
down the least right most assets went
down 90 95 99 bitcoin went down about 80
85
and so it feels like the blue chips
those kind of larger market cap assets
uh they have less volatility both up and
down whereas the long tail uh has much
more of that volatility there's just
smaller less dollars to actually move
that's kind of what you're talking about
here when you think about us now in a
bear uh bull market makes sense why
you're allocated the way you are will
you then look to kind of consolidate
into the large caps in a bear market if
you think that's where we're headed or
do you yeah or like how do you think
about the transition
i'm trying to get my head around this
and i'm thinking that
yes i will move down the risk curve back
to the safer assets where i think
there's less volatility you can use you
know some yield from stable coins or
staking or whatever to lower your
volatility and then you want to be
looking to buy the speculative end of
the market that's going to get destroyed
whether it's parts of the nft space or
parts of the kind of general token space
that gets destroyed in the next bear
market to buy those when they're heavily
discounted but they still have network
adoption effects or some perceived value
or cash flow
that becomes really interesting because
then you can start allocating in the
middle of a bear market into the riskier
assets to buy them super cheap and
that's typical of credit markets
and equity markets people always do the
same and that's where you get the alpha
from is getting this asset allocation
right
and very few people do it because
they're they're still a little bit
blink into one project
and the idea is you can believe the
whole space goes up you can even have
total belief in one project but it's a
long time to get there so
is your allocation waited correctly for
you to reduce the volatility a bit so
you can sleep at night in the bad times
and get a bit of extra out performance
in the good times
i want to talk through uh kind of
various assets i'll just kind of throw
out you know kind of a corner of the
industry uh or one of the main assets in
the industry you just riff on you know
kind of your current thoughts of them so
let's start with bitcoin as kind of the
largest uh market cap asset where do you
think we are with bitcoin with adoption
and kind of from a market structure
standpoint
so
bitcoin from a market structure has been
incredibly bullish the pattern now you
know the chart pattern looks very
similar to a smaller version of the one
from
from march to june 2020 uh where it
exploded we've had this lovely
corrective phase we see all the
unchained stuff you know william
clemente show you know
and willie and all those guys showing
that it's all going into good strong
hands we had the china fudd we've had a
bunch of fun
this usually and there's no guarantees
usually october november december is
ridiculously good particularly at this
point in the halving cycle so
structure it looks amazing so okay who
are the buyers here so most people who
got into crypto
came in by bitcoin that's always the
case it's the it's the big daddy asset
and then people move out the risk curve
and that's pretty normal
so who's the next big bar of bitcoin
it's pretty clear to me who they are it
is the ongoing institutions i mean that
just keeps going and i think we'll set
an acceleration in that particularly if
the price breaks out because
everybody's like sheep they always want
to follow each other
secondly it is the the coming etf it's
definitely gonna well definitely i don't
know that but i just have a very strong
feeling it comes in the next you know
over this october november december
period and that will drive a huge amount
of money in the space because it allows
ras to allocate and ordinary individuals
in a way that they can easily understand
and finally i think
we're starting to see noise from the
sovereign wealth funds so i know some of
them and i've talked about this before
with you is some of them already
allocated but i think we're going to
start to see more sovereign wealth
activity in the space ethereum and in
the ether asset
so ethereum um again the charts look
absolutely astonishing the on-chain
activity the adoption is is
by far the largest of anything in the
space so it's huge what's going on the
move towards 2.0 means that you know at
a simple level everybody's going to
stake everything they've got to get it
there and so that takes all the coins
off the market there's about 11 percent
of all ethan
so it's almost unbuyable so you bring a
whale into the market the price just
explodes so i've never really seen a
setup as good as this
um in that respect so
i think it's it's it's a very high
quality bet for the time being because
of all of this stuff that's either off
exchange being staked and there's no
free supply and demand keeps going
exponential so um
i like keith overall what's interesting
is to start to see institutional
adoption
so i spoke at um cowen's big event and
it wasn't about bitcoin it was solely
about ethereum which took me by surprise
that's the first one i've done
it's kind of been referenced in other
ones but here i am now speaking to
investment banks when they're asking me
to come and talk about ethereum and just
skipping bitcoin saying well we assume
you know bitcoin but here's another
opportunity so i think there's a lot
more adoption to come in that space and
i think there's going to be etf there
too and again with this
really restricted supply that's going on
because of ether 2.0 i think it drives
prices a lot when you think about the
institutions uh that are thinking about
or talking about ethereum and ether is
it because they've already allocated to
bitcoin or do you see some of them
coming in and they're basically actually
skipping over bitcoin
you know um i think there are some that
are skipping over bitcoin
because they get their head around it in
a different way because they think of it
as a way of playing the entire
technology of the space
um so then they don't
you know it's hard for many of these
institutions to stomach the narrative
the bitcoin narrative of a store of
value that central banks are destroying
the world and a lot of this stuff
because that kind of goes against a bit
of their business model
but ethereum is not as
um
it doesn't feel like it's attacking them
as much because it's like here's a space
and we're building decentralized finance
on it and and you know everybody can be
participate um it doesn't feel that they
have to change their internal narratives
some are finding it just a bit easier to
get their heads around what it is
without kind of going against or kind of
exposing the wizard of oz which is the
central banks and what they're doing to
currencies overall
let's talk about uh what i'll call
ethereum competitors maybe some of them
aren't necessarily competitive they're
more complementary but uh like the smart
contract platform so this is uh polka
dot this is solana and there's all kind
of a whole group of those that are out
there how do you look at those assets
um so all i do is look at adoption
effects because i'm not smart enough to
figure out what change better than what
and who why they want to build on it etc
etc but interestingly as i've mentioned
before
ethereum is exactly following i mean
exactly following bitcoin in 2017 in
both price and price structure
bitcoin is following bitcoin 2013 which
is fascinating um in price structure but
not in price itself
um
you know and then
what so i thought you know what i bet
you solana is following um ethereum in
2017 if anybody was in that market at
that time ethereum was the rocket ship
that took everybody by surprise and
guess what it's exact chart fit
and the prices are the same so ethereum
so solana is exactly following um
ethereum ethereum's exactly following
bitcoin it's like the magic is all in
this network adoption and it kind of all
makes sense
the other two that are in that kind of
fast growth fast adoption pays phase
where you see exponential price rises
more than anything else um is obviously
terror
probably avalanche and probably um
polka dots and i think you know they
will all do well in this cycle and like
ethereum they'll go down a lot later um
and then from that we'll see how it
builds out but it kind of it's bizarrely
consistent i never thought this would be
the case because you see all the people
online it's like my project my project
but when you net balance it all out and
just apply like adoption effects and do
these things look similar they're almost
identical which is amazing one of the
things that i've always been surprised
by is uh the folks in silicon valley who
kind of missed a lot of this uh there's
plenty of people who didn't miss it but
the people who did uh you would think
that they would understand it because
what we do know from let's say mobile
apps or some sort of like social network
products etc is those network effects
look very similar and so if you can
start to understand kind of a k
coefficient in the growth uh and really
understand kind of the slopes of those
lines or kind of uh how quickly they're
accelerating you can with pretty good
accuracy predict here's how many users
the company's going to have on this date
and this date and this date and it feels
like that's a little bit of what's
happening here right
there's always the question of is it
sustainable will people continue to
adopt it and you know make sure that
it's an acceleration of the trend
but it does feel like there is some
predictability to some of these assets
as long as that network effect takes
hold and it kind of takes off
yeah and i you know none of us would
have thought this but it kind of
explains why plan b's model works
because i think some way it's showing
the same thing in a different way with
network adoption and how it drives price
and it seems that yes so consistent that
it is pretty forecastable now we don't
know how the cycle's going to play out
now you know what's gonna happen in the
um you know in the bear market when does
that come does it come in the same
structure i do think it probably
decouples to a certain extent
um because i think the adoption is going
to be
really quite big so that lowers as a
network gets more adopted the volatility
lowers so i think we're going to see
that this time around and it will
decouple i also think the cycle goes on
longer um just because of two key
factors one is 2.0 will probably be i
think the end of the cycle because
everybody will um once it unlocks um
people will sell some of their that eat
that they put in for the staking i think
that's a pretty common thing to do that
happens around probably around tax
season as well so people realize gains
and then in addition
i think the
the etf will have come out at that point
and a lot of the the pent-up demand will
be in and then we have to deal with a
bunch of people who don't yet realize
how to deal with
the uh
70 80 volt asset you know it's you know
and you've spent a long time doing this
we all have is to teach people how to
hold how in a network adoption effect
model you will get volatility but is
more than compensated by price if your
time horizon is long enough
and we're gonna have to teach all of
these rias this because they're all
gonna panic out so yeah there's a lot of
work for us all to do to get people to
understand how to deal with high ball
assets and what it means as well you
know what it could mean if they do hold
on how do you think about centralization
versus decentralization um specifically
around you know i uh always laugh the
bitcoiners yell at the ethereum
community you're not decentralized
you're moving more centralized then the
ethereum community yells at the binance
smart chain community and says hey
you're not uh decentralized you're too
centralized and you kind of just go down
the line um and you know whatever the
truth ends up being how do you think
about the importance of decentralization
from like an investment perspective
it's risk curve
that's why bitcoin sits at the top of
the wrist pile right at the bottom of
the wrist poly the foundation asset
because it is the most decentralized
you know it's not rocket science and
eath is a little bit different
okay that's fine um but once you go
further out
they become less decentralized so
they'll risk your assets doesn't mean
they don't play a role
they can't play the role necessarily of
being that kind of reserve asset that
i've talked about in the past and the
pristine collateral because they do have
a risk element which is hard as a price
which bitcoin doesn't have so again it's
just risk curves for me and it it's more
than consistent
with you know if you want to get a
faster chain
you're going to have less um
a more centralized chain and therefore
it should be riskier
get the right point in the risk curve
it'll go up it also means that generally
tend to be lower fees so you tend to get
fast network adoption so these things
can go up a lot
now
what plays out in five years time or ten
years time who the hell knows which ones
survive which one's full by the wayside
which ones get replaced none of us can
know that but just keeping to that
generalized framework what's being
adopted you know what are you trying to
do at this point in the cycle how much
risk you're trying to take and therefore
allocate your assets accordingly let's
talk about nfts uh obviously those have
taken the world by storm uh it seems
like we've gone through a couple of
different iterations of them so uh there
was the nba top shot then there was
crypto punks and there was board ape
yacht club uh now it feels like there's
a gazillion different animals and photos
etc that are being shared on my twitter
feed every day uh and i've frankly just
lost count how do you look at maybe
what's happened to date with nfts and
then we can talk about what's gonna
happen in the future but like what's
your evaluation of it
so we kind of all of us have been
talking about for a few years now that
everything's going to be tokenized and
we're all waiting was it going to be
real estate that went first wasn't going
to be the securities industry we didn't
really know and it ended up being the
art market i mean i would have thought
it but that's what happened and so here
we go attaching
a non-fungible value
to a specific digital asset
and now it's tradable and guess what
suddenly they appreciate a lot in value
because that's an attractive attribute
in this kind of modern age
but it's so that was the first part of
it
the nba top shots was just basically the
same ethos as well if it works for art
then it should work for other
collectibles if it's a digital
collectible like a top shot then it
should have value and it should be
transferable and it becomes collectible
work perfectly
the next phase was this kind of weird
phase which was
well we want to identify with others
like ourselves online
by being part of a community which is
identified by an nft
and as an nft holder much like a
membership of soho house or whatever it
is it gives me some sort of status
symbol online
so that was where that started and then
that's fast developing into
communities that are saying well we've
now gathered a group of people we're
combined because of this one asset we're
seeing gary vee doing this from scratch
which is okay the idea is now let's get
the community and build like a media
business from the ground up based from
this community around these assets and
if we do it these assets can be worth a
lot and we can create a business from
the ground up so in lies the rise of
dows and all of this kind of
decentralized
business stuff so it's it's happening at
a pace that i can't get my head around i
put a tweet out yesterday
to reach out to get some more help on
this because
you know i had a long chat with um
famous hedge fund manager
on sunday and he's all over the art
market and he's kind of got that he
thinks the whole modern art market
is going to collapse in price on a
relative basis and that who the hell are
you going to sell damien hurst to
because
that was a meme of the time of the
late 90s and early 2000s
and it's not applicable to the average
millennial or gen z now so who do you
sell that art to in due course and this
is a complete flipping of the art market
from physical to digital now it doesn't
mean that all digital um physical art is
worth less but that kind of more
speculative
um meme driven
modern art side of stuff
can flip
so i think that's an interesting process
and and you know there's so many things
to get our heads around as you said
there's
there's so many of these bloody
um nfts now of different animals what
does it mean
um but i take it seriously people like
bill ty have got involved with um
um with um unchained monkey and i'm like
well bill was the guy who invested in
crypto kitties and zoom and bill's no no
stupid guy and he sees more on it what
am i missing and i i don't know what i'm
missing yet i just know i'm missing a
lot because i can see it happening at a
pace that i've not seen before and it
feels like the early days of bitcoin
where word of mouth spread super fast
and it was happening on different
channels that most people could see but
it happened really quickly and i think
that's what's going on
talk to us about social tokens i know
you've uh tweeted about that a bunch
you've talked about it in other podcasts
and interviews what what is the social
token and why are you so excited about
it
so we talk about communities and we have
communities online you have a community
i have a community so
so what do we do with communities right
now like this
um
podcast has to now go on a third-party
platform and of which you know they can
put advertising against it you'll get
some of the share you basically don't
own your audience and you've got an
email list so that helps but other
people don't
so what what tokenizing communities do
it basically says okay we're all
like-minded interested people we believe
in this community and we want to
participate in it and that gives you a
direct relationship both financial and
otherwise with people in your network or
community so what are these communities
well communities are just ways that
humans socially
um congregate around ideas so that's the
same as religions states
and a whole number of things you know
you could be you know a member of a well
even let's use soho house
you know you think that that's a
community you want to be part of because
you want to mix with the people in it
and it gives you certain benefits
great but
to to help
navigate and coalesce the power of
community
these are known as complex adaptive
societies and all of them share similar
attributes that tends to be some sort of
leader or group of leaders and that can
be distribute distributed or it can be a
single person
there tends to be a community set of
rules how we adhere kind of a mission
and then what we were missing
was a system of money or value exchange
because then you're basically setting up
sovereign states of individual
communities and those become incredibly
valuable if the network grows it's the
same network effect thing
so if you were a pop star
and you
have
30 million
fans
well before you could had you had to
access your fans via facebook and google
and and via ticketmaster and a whole
bunch of different things
but once we start rolling out social
tokens that changes that whole dynamic
because now they have a financial
interest
in the network which is i.e what you do
and the value that you create for your
community whether it's new songs or
giving them an ability to get tickets
sooner or be able to build businesses on
top you know selling merchandise and
getting paid in tokens and all of the
things that create a rich network
all of this is coming because this
invention of internet money essentially
and the exchange of value has now meant
that communities can be supercharged and
you're not giving it away to third
parties you're in fact sharing the
rewards
with the network and that's incredibly
powerful as a business model and it's
without question viral and it's going to
be everywhere it's going to be we're
already seeing it in sports teams but
that's going to deepen out and explode
we're going to see it in
musicians and rock stars we're seeing it
you know it came out people like rac or
very early in doing this
but we're also going to say in mega
brands you know mega brands are already
starting to get into the nft market you
know there's been some great moves by um
dolce gabbana
and a few others where they're starting
to experiment with this and the
metaverse
but there's going to be tokenizations
amongst those fan bases i mean nike
could basically tokenize and there's no
reason peloton won't tokenize and all of
these businesses and it's going to
create a layer of value
above that of equity it's a whole
different layer because you're valuing
the network properly
which is not usually done in the equity
so
it's a fast and a fascinating thing i've
got two of my brothers here with me and
they got a couple of questions as well
what do you guys got hey ro thanks for
doing this i appreciate you coming on uh
so my question would be just kind of
around the total market cap of all of
all crypto assets and cryptocurrencies
so we're at around 2 trillion today
if we were to kind of fast forward 5 10
15 years from now where do you think
this number can go and kind of how do
you get there
so i think it goes
very interesting i've just got a chart
of of adoption of the internet and
crypto maps it beautifully except the
internet was growing at 63 a year when
it it had 150 million users which crypto
has now
so it's growing 63 a year crypt is
growing at 113 so this is double the
adoption rate of the fastest um adoption
of technology in all recorded history so
we've never seen anything like this
extrapolate the maths you get out to a
billion people by 2024. so this is going
to happen really really fast by the end
of the decade you're probably at three
and a half four billion people so most
of the world
so
what does that mean for asset prices
well almost all the major asset classes
whether it's equities bonds real estate
they're all kind of in the
150 to 300 trillion dollar range now we
kind of know that most of those assets
are going on the blockchain anyway but
let's ignore that
to put this where i think it's going
it's currently 2 trillion i think
a roughly fair value to fit in with the
other asset classes
is 200 trillion so it's 100x
uh we've never had a asset
do 100x of that kind of magnitude
in all recorded history i mean we've
never seen it before none of us have
lived through this
so this is i think
going to be the largest
um generation of wealth that the world
has seen in the shortest period of time
john what questions you got yeah thanks
very for doing this nice to meet you um
i'm curious about your thoughts around
solana and kind of how you allocate two
different altcoins do you buy them all
at once do you kind of dollar cost
average and see where the market goes
what are your thoughts around that
um generally you fomo into these things
because they're ripping and then you buy
them too high and they correct for
another few weeks and you're like an
idiot they're really hard because you
don't know what's going to explode you
have to be really in the space to see
where the adoption's happening so what i
did first is i bought a basket of maybe
15 different tokens
across everything from d5 to these new
layer ones
and then i kind of assessed i kind of
chucked a couple out that i was like i
don't really know much about this i'm
not seeing much kind of network behavior
online where people are talking about it
as much um and then try to
add into places where i thought that
could be
um
better outcomes such as solana but you
know i can't
take full risk in it i understand that
people can because they're in the space
i'm just not deep enough in all these
protocols to do that so i just have to
accept that the tail is going to go up
if i can get good quality within the
tail i don't need to do the most
speculative assets i don't really want
to do that but
other people can and that's fine
but i think this middle ramp is where
you can make some really great returns
and that's kind of proven out to be the
case so far
good to know well when you think about
uh the metaverse uh you started to kind
of go down that path a little bit i know
that you're really excited about this
where do you think
one that kind of starts to really
permeate society and then also two how
do you think about it from an investor
seat in terms of how to get exposure to
it uh for your own portfolio
i think if it's the ongoing process the
fact that you and i when we did this the
last interview in 20 not the last one
that that that big interview in 2020 we
had to do in person
right now
you assume right we're now living
digitally
and me seeing you i mean i have you know
drinks with friends on zoom it's normal
now i don't it doesn't bother me right
so we've now moved a massive step into
the digital world where just meeting our
friends or meeting people we know
can happen over video link and we don't
really care much like to happen with
mobile phones and phones before that
and television and all of these things
so this is an ongoing move into the
digital world and then it accelerates
because you start to see the rise of
cryptocurrency and that enables these
ecosystems to develop into these rich
worlds where you can create value
exchange value own things so this
creates the other layer then the layers
on top of that come 5g distributed
computing power and a bunch of other
things that are going to scale that
faster so once you've got the computing
power because right now most of our
computers are not gaming computers so we
can't render in the speed we need to
render so we get left with crypto voxels
and decentralized being clunky and all
of the cool kids are on epic games and
they've got 4k but we don't have the
computing power to do it
all of that is going to change so all
this is the metaverse it gets thought of
in so many ways for me it's like our
digital fluidity where we can live and
move around in this digital space
interact with our physical space whether
it's through augmented reality
virtual reality
uh just normal kind of
digital world
and we can kind of
create lives within it so we're creating
income streams we're seeing that with
actually infinity right now or we can we
can be educated in the metaverse that
kind of levels the playing field i mean
you can be a kid in ethiopia and you can
therefore
now
get educated on the same playing field
as somebody in the united states because
we have access and you can be in the
same classroom and get to talk to them
so
just things everywhere are going to
change because of this and you know it's
going to happen because
everybody from microsoft to facebook to
apple have basically said this is the
bet it's augmented reality virtual
reality the metaverse you know i spoke
to the head of metaverse who knew there
was one at aws
and they're building out the computing
power and the cloud storage abilities
for all of these massive compute needs
right so it's happening now the battle
is going to be as ever
the same battle decentralized versus
centralized and as ever it'll be a
mixture of both and we get to choose
um but that's all coming and that's a
hugely exciting thing and people haven't
really figured this out yet but again
it's going to be an enormous generator
of wealth as the world moves into the
digital world i got two more questions
for you first one is around regulation
we've seen everyone from uh politicians
in the united states and internationally
we've seen uh the cftc the sec the occ
uh a whole bunch of alphabet soup of
organizations i didn't even know existed
that are all weighing in with their
opinions on various parts of the
industry what's your read on the
regulatory uh situation and kind of the
rule set both in the u.s and
internationally
firstly the reason you hear from all
those agencies is there's a fight going
on to who's to regulate it right is it a
commodity is it a currency is it a
security right so that's clear that
they've got a ship fight going on
and jerome is um sorry not jerome um
against us flexing his muscles and being
the loudest about it
meanwhile you get these snarky comments
from the others like it's not all down
to him so that has to be decided so
basically what we have to do is decide
how to do this
so against us making his play he's
saying well everything's a security
fine if you want to define it that way
that's okay too
security doesn't make it illegal or a
terrible thing i mean apple's a security
and so is a u.s treasury so that's okay
but what you're going to have to do
is change what securities laws what that
means because if you are going to stop
the pace of development and innovation
you're going to shoot yourself in the
foot and it will be
arbitraged away by going to different
jurisdictions
so the u.s is hampered by this
ridiculous 1934 securities law
um and the howie test so people use that
as the big thing see it's a security
it's like but that doesn't mean there's
criminal activity it means how you issue
something and who's allowed to buy it is
somewhat restricted now is that the
right thing to do is this what the world
should
should be doing should we be restricting
young people with less savings from this
new exciting technology or not my view
is we should not much like we shouldn't
stop them investing in startups we
should give them warnings we should give
them understanding some education about
what they're doing but people need to be
allowed to do this
because they're allowed to go to vegas
they're allowed to throw all of their
pay in all of their life savings and
nobody gives a [ __ ] zero regulations
they can lend it to their uncle who
steals it no regulations but heaven
forbid if you buy something that's
listed as a security you know the
ridiculous laws around um accredited
investors it's just morally wrong and it
doesn't stand up so i think this is the
battle that's going to get fought
i think the battle is gensler is laying
out the hard case everything's security
we're going to start prosecuting people
and then we'll figure it out and i think
the industry is going to coalesce along
with
voters we're going to coalesce around
yeah but if you turn it into the the um
securities industry that we grew up with
we're not going to accept it and so
there's going to be a fight and that
fight will lead to a grand compromise
and that grand compromise was exactly
what happened to the internet regulation
and mo and phone regulations beforehand
it will come
but it won't be easy so my guess is the
you know if we do have another bear
market phase
that comes in somewhere in 2022
i think it starts later
2022 2023 it's all going to be about the
fight of regulation and that mixed
signal that's going to keep people away
from the space and it's going to push
innovation to countries where it's
clearer such as south korea or singapore
and other countries where they've made
the regulation much clearer so there's a
lot to play for here it's going to get
ugly
but
classic negotiation skills that always
start with a hard line because it gives
you the upper hand because what you're
trying to do is there's the middle line
you're trying to get it incrementally
over the middle line further in your
direction and guenzo wants that because
he regulates securities so of course he
does now
and our job is to get it somewhere
across the other side and the answer is
going to be somewhere in the middle
let's see who wins
i think that's probably a very fair uh
view of it and i agree that uh all of
the different organizations are trying
to figure out who gets what uh in this
which is a crazy thing because there's a
lot of technology a lot of jobs a lot of
economic impact that is kind of hanging
in the back and think about what happens
if if what i think is going to happen is
this 2 trillion is maybe 10 trillion by
let's say march of next year what are
you going to do then
what are you going to do with the nfts
what are you going to do with these
social tokens what are you going to do
with d5
you you cannot go back find a bunch of
people say you were naughty
who's the voice of god here who knows
what d5 protocol is going to survive and
which one is
what some some guy in the sec goes this
is a a good project and that's a bad
no the market makes that decision that
is the job of the market you just have
to warn people what risks they're taking
um so
yeah there has to be a change and
you know people have to
have to be allowed to take risk now
you're seeing the younger generation
taking more risk than was traditional
for us
and the reason being is options
robin hood and they're like [ __ ] it i've
got my one chance and they're taking
more risk
that's good there's nothing wrong with
risk taking just as long as people
understand options are great because you
can only lose what you put in now if you
put in your life savings that's a pretty
stupid thing but you see it on wall
street bets that they kind of
acknowledge that
and they laugh about their losses but
what you're doing is mass educating all
of these people about risk taking and i
think they're going to be larger risk
takers
than our generation the gen x's were or
the um particularly the baby boomers
that were much less risk takers so it's
fascinating what's playing out the other
piece of it too i think is uh they're
going further and further out on the
risk curve because they have to right
there's only so many there's only so
many assets they can buy that actually
have a real rate of return and so
naturally what do you do is if i can't
buy bonds well there goes 40 of the
traditional portfolio so what do i do
with that money do i put it in stocks
well you know some stocks are doing well
some aren't and you just kind of
continue to move out and then there are
digital uh natives and so naturally it
makes sense that they end up in uh in
bitcoin you know in cryptocurrency and
they have an informational advantage
so good on them right because i'm the
idiot who's trying to figure it out but
these guys have been born in that world
of course they don't have to figure
anything out it's just normal
all right i want to wrap up with the
question we ask everyone we need a
bitcoin price prediction by end of year
and i need an ethereum price prediction
by end of year what do you got for us
i was doing some work on this on the
weekend for global macro investor i'm
kind of thinking
i'm kind of a little bit overly bullish
right now
um and i think the cycle well no because
that's not fair because i was looking at
the cycle itself i think bitcoin
somewhere north of
200 and eth closer to
15k
but i think we finished the cycle
with bitcoin close to 400 and each
closer to 40 000.
all right so you think by end of year
we've got bitcoin 200k or so we've got
ethe at 15k you think end of cycle which
in your opinion sounds like kind of
february march of next year something
like that yeah bitcoin's 400 000 and eth
is 40 000. yeah
i uh there's a lot of people watching
who hope you're right
i bloody hope so too it's not like i
haven't backed my own bet so
my money's where my mouth is i hear you
all right tell us a little bit uh about
real vision and where can we send people
if they want to check out real vision
all the great content you guys are doing
there yeah look the easiest thing is if
you're interested in crypto we've got a
entire channel we've built for it called
real vision crypto
it's free all you need is pop your email
address and it's wall-to-wall content
every friday um i i've got my own show
which is called rails adventures in in
crypto and there i'm interviewing the
most interesting people i can find to
get my knowledge up so you can follow me
on that journey so
realvisioncrypto.com or realvision.com
forward slash crypto it's free i urge
you to sign up it's there for you it's a
resource that we built for everybody
because this is the most exciting
dynamic space i've ever seen so that's
the that's the best way and you can
always find me on twitter at
um r-a-o-u-l-g-m-i
you uh you got some of the best uh the
best threads i love when i think that
you're just sitting there you're like
you know what i got something to say you
just go on one of these uh you just rip
off a thread and i'm like man that is
just a stream of thoughts that people
needed to hear because that's pretty
damn good
yeah just trying to think this all
through you know because none of us know
the answers
so to think it through put it out there
get it tested it's good
i love it the uh as you can imagine the
comments love four hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin and 40k eth you're uh
you're gaining fans by the second so
[Laughter]
awesome listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this i highly
suggest anybody uh who's watching this
go check out uh real vision crypto or
follow role on twitter and we will have
to do this again my friend
always and we'll get you on on our side
of the fence soon as well all right
sounds good talk soon all right take
care of them all right thank you